on this Dr Martin Luther King Jr day we
not only celebrate his life but also his
legacy and how it continues to inspire
Generations Victoria Saha tells us how
sir to their goals
having a dream to start your own
business doesn't have to be an
impossible goal on this Martin Luther
King Jr day and black business owners in
our area say they're taking Dr King's
dream to the next level by making an
impact in our community by working
together when you walk in here and see
that your products are pretty much
almost sold out what's that feeling like
fulfilling yeah it means everything
everything 34 year old Hassan tesfa
dreamed of when he first started his
business called CMOS prime a wellness
drink CMOS is it's an algae one of many
that has a lot of anti-inflammatory
benefits it's something tespa says he
grew up with in Jamaica but wanted to
introduce to the Las Vegas market and
starting wasn't easy okay why you I had
to establish myself give out samples of
course and just be consistent so where I
got it from and make sure that it was
certified make sure it was safe that's
where Global Soco came in a non-profit
dedicated to helping other black owned
businesses like task for get a boost we
have digital tools that we allow people
to get access to like microfinancing and
e-commerce systems that allow people to
go Global Tommy Richardson is the
director of operations for Global Soca
we met up with him at the Martin Luther
King Jr parade on Monday we're allowing
the people that MLK address which is the
world to work together and take
empowerment to the next level and it's
businesses like trust fuzz that Global
Soco took to the next level by helping
him get his website started to reach a
diverse audience something he doesn't
take lightly while remembering Dr King
towards the end of his life he was
really big on black empowerment right so
I mean for me being an entrepreneur
that's everything Victoria Saha eight
news now global Soco has helped more
than 4 000 businesses get started if you
want to learn more on how to collaborate
with them just click on this story
you'll find that on 8newsnow.com